with a new influx of migrants heading to
the United States Southern border every
day Washington is going back to an old
strategy planning to build a new section
of Border W although it's only 32 km
long in one part of southern Texas
President Biden tried to distance
himself from the measure telling
reporters that Congress wouldn't let him
spend the money any other way the border
wall the money was appropriated for the
border wall I tried to get them to
reappropriate to redirect that money
they didn't they wouldn't and in the
meantime there's nothing under the law
other than they have to use the money
for what it was appropriated I can't
stop them do you believe the border wall
Works no but the news broke just as high
level talks between the two governments
began leaving the Mexican president
visibly
unimpressed this authorization for the
construction of the wall is a step
backwards because it doesn't solve the
problem doesn't solve the
problem the causes must be addressed I
those causes are many economic meltdown
in Venezuela hunger and gang violence in
Haiti authoritarian governments in Cuba
and Nicaragua to name just a few not
just the US Secretary of State but the
attorney general and Secretary of
Homeland Security were in Mexico for the
talks it wasn't just migration on the
agenda they took place in Mexico's
national Palace just behind us the
United States wanted to talk about fenel
the synthetic drug that's are one of the
leading causes of death in Americans
from 18 to 49 years old they want
Mexican authorities to do more to stop
criminals bringing it in here cooking it
up and then smuggling it Stateside the
Mexican Government on the other hand
wants the United States to do more to
prevent weapons coming from the United
States into Mexico and contributing to
this country's Skyhigh homicide
rate but it was the border that
dominated the new news conference that
wrapped up the visit strict consequences
for those who do not use those lawful
means to enter our country those
consequences include Swift repatriation
the Swift return of migrants and a ban
on their
re-entry just today the United States
announced its agreement with the country
of Venezuela to
repatriate Venezuelan Nationals who do
not take advantage of the lawful
Pathways and instead arrive irregularly
at our Southern border and do not
qualify for
Relief by Thursday night the visit had
ended but the long running issues
between the two countries remain John
Holman Al jazira Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer